Speaker 1: Let's go next to Veiga from Oklahoma.
Hey, David, how's it going?
It's going well, thank you.
Speaker 5: So I was watching the Texas Democrats
yesterday, and honestly, it's very exciting
that they got to go over to Washington, D.C..
Yeah.
Yes, so what do you think about progress on
the voting rights legislation like H.R. one
and H.R. four and also the infrastructure
package they just revealed the three point
five trillion dollar package today.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So on the on voting rights, I'm not hugely
optimistic about the bill.
I've this has been my view for some time.
And as I'm sure you know, Veiga, I would immediately
change my opinion if the facts change.
That's just the type of guy I am.
I'm not very optimistic on the Voting Rights
Act on infrastructure.
I am more optimistic.
I think Joe Biden desperately needs another
major accomplishment.
And I'm hoping that it is going to be that
it is going to have a low.
Yes, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: OK.
Oh, sorry, sorry, your voice went out for
a sec.
Speaker 1: All right, Veiga, thank you very
much for the call.
I appreciate it.
A lot of important questions today and glad
to have the opportunity to answer them.
Let's go next to oh, I don't know.
How about Daniel from California, also known
as RU New Grundler.
Speaker 4: Hello, David.
Hello.
Yes, so like my username Nug Wrangler suggests,
I'm going to be blunt, so when I see you're
going to be on the show, I know the possibility
was teased last year shortly after winning
the race to a million subscribers.
Speaker 1: Any time she wants, it's wide open.
We've we've reached out a couple of times
and haven't heard back.
She may be too big for this show.
Right?
I'm not delusional, but she's welcome.
Absolutely any time.
Speaker 4: Yeah, definitely and definitely
big.
Well, you're a good interviewer, so I'm sure
you'd have an eloquent way of asking her how
she juggles idealism with pragmatism.
And I also wanted to know what she would have
thought of my prediction, worthless prediction
that it will be AOC versus Ivonka in twenty
twenty four.
Speaker 1: It will not be AOC versus Ivonka
in twenty twenty four, but I will make a note
of it and ask her about in some way I guess,
if she's ever on the show.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well I'm a gambler.
I, you know, I roll the dice so that's my
bet.
Speaker 1: Are you actually betting on that.
I mean you could probably get action on that
if you really felt that was going to happen.
You probably got a thousand to one odds.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I'm being a membership, OK?
All right, very good with the illegal discount
codes, so it's affordable.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Speaker 4: Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, thanks very much.
Listen, I'm going to tell you right now, be
very careful with those discount codes.
I don't want anybody ending up in prison as
a result
of them.